Is Islam more than just a religion?
But Islam is not a religion.
I know it sounds crazy
and I know I don't get a lot of support for that idea.
But I strongly believe that Islam
might be dressed up as a religion.
I always use one example to prove it.
There are many more that like and communism are fascism.
The penalty is death
if you want to leave it.
I mean, you cannot leave Islam
if you are on apostate,
if you are renegades,
the penalty is death.
And even today in our societies,
let alone in the Islamic societies,
it is unacted upon.
You know, people are killed for that reason.
You can leave Christianity.
You can leave Judaism.
So, um, um, and the other point is that
Islam wants to rule the world.
As you know,
Islam means to subjugate,
wants to rule and dominate and subjugate
not only a person's life,
but also a whole society.
You know, the rule of god,
the rule of,
of Allah, the rule of the Quran and Hadid is,
is the rule of the society.
You know, they are not,
I'm not talking about all Muslims.
I'm talking about the ideology.
And the ideology
cannot integrate and assimilate in a society,
wants to dominate it.
And I want to subjugate with violence.
The Quran is full of more violence and anti semitism
than mankind.
For instance. People,
academics have proved that.